well you may have thought that the uh st
st louis university saga was over now
that my much protested event was uh was
already held and
that's all in the past now
but that doesn't appear to be the case
we are reminded that the administration
officials there uh the ones who run most
of these leftist universities are not
only partisan but also vindictive and
petty
just really bad people
they hold grudges they seek to punish
students who run afoul of them
ideologically and they'll grab hold of
any pretense however superficial or
facile it might be in order to do that
which brings us to slu student james
dowling who faces the possibility of
expulsion from school
for hanging flyers advertising my event
two weeks ago
uh and it gets even more absurd than
that so this is from the daily signal it
reports st university st louis
university is threatening to expel or
suspend a student for posting flyers
advertising the daily wired matt well
daily wires matt walsh's off-campus
speaking event according to the young
americas foundation the student james
dowling was told in a december 9th video
conference with school administrators
that he could face expulsion for his
inappropriate conduct
and quote failure to comply according to
yaf dowling a member of the st
louis university college republicans
group was putting up flyers advertising
walsh's off-campus event on december 1st
when nearby slu administrators
uncomfortable with the presence of slu's
name on the same flyer as the slu
college republicans told him to take
them take them down according to yef
dowling reportedly offered to cross out
the names on the flyers with a marker
but the administrators wouldn't accept
the compromise
now
the thing to keep in mind here is that
my event was off campus
and the flyers were also off campus so
this is an off-campus event
where the advertising is also happening
off campus
which means that it's entirely outside
of the jurisdiction of the university
narcs who came to harass james
dowling
it has nothing to do with that
outside of their jurisdiction
they are not police officers
they have no right to tell anyone what
they can or cannot do off campus
especially when the offense is simply
hanging a flyer and not a defensive
flyer either by the way there was
nothing on the flyer there was no
offensive imagery
just a picture of me which you know
maybe some people would say is offensive
imagery but just a picture of me and
then saying what event it is and that's
it really standard flyer
back to the article it says in a letter
dated december 9th the slu office of
student responsibility and community
standards sent dowling a letter
detailing his alleged breaches of slu's
community standards the letter also
noted that dowling would be required to
attend a hearing for his suspendable
violations
this is not yet another case of
politically motivated prosecution by the
office of uh student responsibility
community standards slu college
republican president nicholas baker said
in a statement share with daily caller
after dealing with them when they went
after the club for asking another
organization the slu [ __ ] to define the
word woman and learning the the office's
director distributed copies of the
gender-bred person to students a few
years ago i have no confidence in their
ability to be fair and objective in
their decisions
so that's from the daily card and then
yaf over over on yaf's website they have
a little more information on this so
this is what they say listen to this
during the call with the administration
officials dowling was informed that he
was being charged with both failure to
comply and inappropriate conduct
according to the office of student
responsibility community standards
assistant director william bowie
he was allegedly confrontational
disrespectful and failed to comply with
reasonable requests made by the staff in
accordance with their duties
now dowling did uh contact the city to
make sure that where he was hanging the
flyers
that it did it was in fact off campus it
was city property and not university
property and turns out that it was
city property not university property
i don't have them with me unfortunately
because they won't let you go through
airport security with large sharp knives
but
i want to tell you about candy coated
knives kamikoto taps into more than 800
years of traditional techniques from
honshu japan each kamikota knife goes
through a rigorous 19-step process that
takes several years from start to finish
to complete and when you have these
knives you can tell that there is that
much time put into making them because
of their single beveled edge
chemical knives can achieve an
unbelievably sharp edge that you just
can't get with other knives they can cut
through your rib eye like butter candy
coated knives are used by several chefs
working at michelin star restaurants so
click the link below or go to
cammycoda.com matt walsh and use promo
code matt walsh to save an extra 50
today
so their real claim against dowling
is that the flyers make mention of st
louis university
now i'm highly skeptical that they have
the authority to tell students that they
can't write the name of the school on a
piece of paper and tape it up somewhere
off campus
i'm skeptical that they have that
authority
but even if they do i mean even if they
can tell you that he offered to cross
out the offending phrase anyway
that wasn't good enough for them
and besides pretending that this was
some kind of violation
and that the student hadn't offered a
reasonable compromise let's pretend that
for a second
expulsion
really
yeah that's the penalty he was
explicitly threatened with
on the call with the administration this
uh william bowie person said to him if
you were if you were to be found
responsible for a policy violation
suspension or expulsion from the
institution are included within the
range of possible outcomes that could be
applied
of course these people can never speak
like real human beings everything is
communicated in a bureaucratic parlance
but that's beside the point
keep in mind that earlier this year
members of the uh this slu [ __ ]
organization this group
again that's their name for themselves
it's not my name for them
although as i've said if the shoe fits
wear it you know
but members of that group tore down an
approved pro-life display on campus
because they didn't like it
there's a pro-life display that had been
approved it was on campus
and these self-described [ __ ] went over
and tore it down
that's an act of uh that's an actual
crime that's an act of vandalism
nobody involved in that vandalism has
been threatened with expulsion so far as
i know
so this is quite clearly politically
motivated these are power tripping
bullies
still angry that i managed to have such
a well-attended event despite their best
efforts and now they're taking it out on
some random kid who lacks the resources
to fight back and defend himself this is
a classic bully maneuver
by the way the article on the aft site
mentioned something i thought was it was
a good point
um
whatever happened to the great concern
everyone supposedly has for mental
health and well-being that's the whole
reason that simone biles was just
awarded athlete of the year right by
time or whatever it was
because she's a she's a now
a spokeswoman
a mascot for mental health and mental
health is so important
now this is not the main takeaway here
perhaps but it is worth pointing out
that most of the stuff we hear about
mental health is nonsense
at least the people pretending to care
about it don't
hanging expulsion
over a kid's head because he he he put a
flyer up
off campus
is you know among other things an
assault on his mental health
imagine what kind of stress and anxiety
that might induce
and top it all off this is apparently
finals week
so you've got that stress on top of it
well as always when these people talk
about mental health they mean it in a
very qualified way they care about the
mental health of their tribe
of their um
ideological comrades
but a kid who has signaled that that
he's an enemy by associating himself
with me well he can go to hell
we'll just
we'll we'll kick him out of school let's
cause him immense hardship for no reason
at all
and that's what getting expelled from
college is no that's no small thing
that can haunt you for
your whole life potentially
so let's do that just because we can to
punish him for thinking differently
now this is not uh mere bias in my mind
this is evil
and i can tell you one thing
you know i'm not going to stand for that
slu has already seen what an enormous
pain in the ass i can be
and they don't know the half of it
because i can hold a grudge too and i
can be petty and vindictive too
i think i've demonstrated that
if i've demonstrated anything it's that
so if they move forward with trying to
expel this student they're going to have
many more headaches in the future to
deal with
i promise you that
so just leave this kid alone you damned
sociopaths
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content